والتطورات الميدانيه طبعا في
خنس التطورات الميدانيه في هذا الصباح
كانت
اشتباكات عنيفه كانت قد اندلعت صباح هذا
اليوم في مخيم خانيونس تحديدا في منطقه
الحاووز استمعنا لهذه اشتبكات بشكل واضح
جدا اطلاق نار من اسلحه مختلفه سواء خفيفه
كذلك ثقيله اضافه الى انفجارات عنيفه دوت
في محيط تلك المنطقه في هذا الصباح اضافه
الى ان قوات الاحتلال مازالت تواصل
جريمتها في منطقه خانيونس في مخيم خانيونس
بعمليات اعدام تقوم بها بين الحين والاخر
بحق المدنيين والمواطنين والنازحين في
اكثر من منطقه في المحافظه وتتركز في
منطقه محيط مستشفى ناصر في هذه المنطقه
هناك عده مدارس متواجده في محيط المستشفى
والمواطنون والنازحون داخل هذه المدارس
يحاولون الوصول بين الحين والاخر للمستشفى
لتوفير بعض الخدمات اليوميه مثل المياه
قبل قليل قامت قوات الاحتلال واليات
الاحتلال باطلاق النار باتجاه سيده كانت
تحاول الوصول الى مستشفى ناصر بينما كانت
تحاول ان تقطع الشارع من المدرسه المقابله
لهذا المستشفى لكنها قد اصيبت بعيار ناري
من قبل قناصه الاحتلال وحتى هذه اللحظه
على ما يبدو بان حالتها حرجه جدا وفي اي
لحظه قد يتم الاعلان عن استشهادها خاصه في
ظل ظروف صعبه يعيش ايضا مستشفى ناصر مع
نقص الكوادر الطبيه مع نقص الادويه وعدم
دخول الادويه الى المستشفى هناك مناشدات
عديده تطلق بين الحين والاخر من مدير
مستشفى ناصر بضروره تدخل عاجل وسريع من
اجل توفير ما يلزم داخل هذا المستشفى
لتوفير الخدمه العلاجيه للمرضى والجرحى
والسماح لسيارات الاسعاف التنقل في محيط
المستشفى الذي يتواجد ف عديد من الاصابات
التي تقع في صفوف النازحين سواء في
المدارس المحيطه وكذلك في المنازل
المجاوره لمستشفى ناصر نتحدث ايضا بان
الاشتباكات في اكثر من منطقه بخلاف منطقه
مخيم خنوس ايضا في منطقه حي الامل ما زالت
قوات الاحتلال تتواجد هناك وكذلك تقوم
بعملي اطلاق نار واطلاق قذائف مدفعيه
باتجاه منازل المواطنين في حين مازال هناك
ايضا العشرات والمئات من المواطنين
النازحين داخل مستشفى الامل وفي ظل
محاولات اخراج هؤلاء النازحين لكن الحصار
مطبق على هذا المستشفى من قبل اليات
الاحتلال وتقوم قوات الاحتلال باطلاق
النار وهناك ايضا مناشدات عاجله من قبل
الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني بضروره توفير ممر
امن على غرار ما حدث قبل يومين في تلك
المنطقه حيث ان هناك الالاف من النازحين
والمرضى والطواقم الطبيه داخل المستشفى
وتعاني الامرين في ظل هذا الحصار نتحدث عن
المناطق الشرقيه لمحافظه خان يونس هذه
المناطق ايضا هناك اشتباكات ما بين الحين
والاخر في ظل ان الغارات لم تتوقف خلال
الليله الماضيه وصباح هذا اليوم في محيط
هذه المنطقه التي نتواجد فيها مطقه جزان
النجار تعرض لاحزن ناريه بشكل عنيف خلال
الليله الماضيه وفجر هذا اليوم استهدفت
اراض زراعيه حتى هذه اللحظه نتحدث بان
الاشتباكات وكان هذه الاشتباكات في يومها
الاول من العدوان الاسرائيلي على قطاع غزه
تحتدم هذه الاشتباكات في وسط محافظه خان
يونس في مخيم خان يونس في حي الامل وكذلك
الغارات مستمره من قبل اليات الاحتلال
وكذلك طائرات الاحتلال على اكثر من هدف في
خان يونس